about your background so so I was born
in kieving in the USSR so it's actually
really funny that happened like the way
that the Mind shift has happened in like
Society is everybody always called me
like a Russian guy even though I was
from Ukraine okay and now and now it's
like see I told you I don't why do you
have an accent why because I was nine
years old when I moved really yeah I was
nine and you still had no I'm surprised
Russian's my first language really yeah
Russian's my first your English is
perfect well because it's it's now my
it's my native language now because
that's what I grew up like I finished
high school University everything you
know yeah um I grew up in Vancouver uh
and then so I lived in the Soviet Union
until 92 and Soviet Union collapsed and
we got on an airplane with a suitcase
and there was a rule when you left the
Soviet Union so they said look you were
nine do you have siblings or no just me
just you me Mom and Dad okay and the
rule was you're allowed one suitcase per
family okay and 50 US dollars to leave
wow because they made it really like
they you know so you were nine years old
correct were you like was it scary for
you did you did you know what was going
on no idea so my parents didn't tell me
we were leaving the country for ever
until the day we left because what yeah
because there was a big risk of being
robbed so what would happen is like if
you're telling people I'm going to North
America and it's like cool and then they
would just like come and Rob you because
you know it's like the Soviet Union it's
what 90s were wild at that time it was
just Mafia and Corruption and like
inflation it was just like a crazy place
to be right wow so uh my dad I remember
he's like hey we're going to stay at
Grandma's house I'm like it's Wednesday
but okay and then we got there it was
like Wednesday night he's like hey
tomorrow we leave from Moscow I'm like
where are we going he's like we're
moving to Canada
and I was like I was just like what's
happening Oh Canada to me is like an
imaginary place because back then you
didn't have the like internet you didn't
have you know hundreds of channels on TV
we had three TV channels they're all
Soviet propaganda government channels
right so I don't know anything about the
outside world like the world that I live
in and you know the Soviet Union 92
versus like let's say Canada there was
about a 30-year Gap in development so
everything that this like the the
Canadians and Americans had in 92 right
that was like the Soviet Union was what
North America had in the 60s like the
technology like we had the road you know
the dialy phone with the big ringy thing
we had to call the operator sometimes to
connect us like nobody in the 90s did
that
um so it was just like a very strange
experience obviously because it's at the
time it was like a different planet and
was it traumatizing to you like I mean
I'd imagine you had a whole group of
friends that you just left yeah what was
traumatizing I would say is like
realizing when we arrived in North
America how poor we were that was
actually quite traumatizing because so
you didn't know well in the Soviet Union
everybody's just poor like it's just
normal for your grandma you know to wake
up at five in the morning to go on the
breadline because she has to well you
can't get bread if you're there at eight
in the morning there'll be no more bread
so you know the grandmothers the
retirees would get up super super early
go to the store and then wait in line
for two hours to get a loaf of bread
because they would sell out because
there was always a food shortage it was
always the case in the Soviet Union but
you had no idea no so I remember like
you know I'm on the airplane and I
remember that very very clearly because
we're flying from Moscow to Montreal
then we changed planes and and on the
airplane they give me like this little
Etch A Sketch toy I've never seen that
before I'm like this is a crazy
technology like oh you can draw on it
and then like pull it and the thing
disappears and draw again I saw my first
can of Pepsi I've never seen a can of
soda before in 92 like I never I just
that an exist in the Soviet Union and
then the other thing I remember when we
landed in Vancouver I needed to go pee
and there was a urinal in the urinals I
had no I'm like what I've never seen a
urinal [__] like I just remember
thinking like what is happening what is
this stuff
so would you say
a question it might be but were people
happier in the Soviet Union versus
Canada because it's interesting because
like I asked this question to someone
like an Uber driver the other day that
was from like a third world country and
he he said that people were happier
there I would say but I would imagine it
was so corrupt maybe not I would say it
was a really so this is something I was
actually thinking about this morning
because I woke up literally thinking
that question so I started researching
it this morning I just needed to know
for myself because I was thinking back
to that right like I will introspect and
I'll say this
people in North America
are happier
now let me rephrase that people back
there were happier people back there
were happier but they were less unhappy
than the people in North America
so the reason why I'm trying to say is a
very difficult thing to kind of
comprehend is like people in North
America have a delusional degree of
unhappiness
like the unhappiness you know because
you have like a pretty
comfortable life and then you're
creating problems that don't exist you
know what I mean so so yeah people in
North America are probably both happier
and unhappier at the same time like
there's this like this we have
unhappiness within what should be
perceived as happiness what I say people
in the Soviet Union were happier
you have to ask my parents to probably
go back into the 90s were pretty nuts
what do you think they would say
my dad 100 would say they were happier
back there really 100 yeah wow that's
crazy yeah so what happened when you got
to Canada
well I remember like we went to a
supermarket it was full of food I just I
hadn't seen cereal before so I was like
whoa cereal and cartoons like we got
like a cartoon every week you know
delivered on Soviet propaganda TV and it
was like some same cartoon my parents
grew up on because in the Soviet Union
you know when you kill capitalism when
you kill Innovation nothing's new
so everything's just recycled over and
over so it's like we're literally
watching the same cartoon our parents
watched
so it was like a
Planet yeah yeah and so then what was
school like uh it was tough like I said
I realized very quickly that we were
poor that was a difficult thing because
again back in the Soviet USSR everyone
everyone's just so so it's kind of yeah
just like you felt different from
everyone else because well I got made
fun of because I dress different right
like I just my patches in my pants like
my great grandmother who lived into like
the early 2000s uh would like repair if
I like me had a hole in my classy you
know Soviet sweatpants which is a slobs
that's what we wear you know I had the
track suits yeah and mine had patches on
the knees because my great grandma would
stitch them up like everybody in the
Soviet Union learned different skills
because nothing would get done that you
needed done like if you wanted something
fixed you just have to do it is it hard
when you come on shows like mine and
these girls talk about their trauma and
you're like you know what I mean it's
just you actually came from the Soviet
Union and they're talking about how hard
it was for them you know I mean look I
think I I'm privileged in the sense that
my parents like raised me in one home
and they stayed together and obviously
there's disadvantages some of those
girls had because like they're raised by
a single mom right that has like
profoundly negative consequences on them
like through their adolescence as we see
now like actualize their statistics and
data
um but I mean are there problems pretty
stupid yeah they're pretty stupid but
you can't tell them that yeah so we went
to Canada and then where'd you go to
school uh so I went uh to high school
and Elementary School in Vancouver and
then UBC University British Columbia and
Vancouver for University okay and what
was that like
um UBC was a really interesting
experience so again this was kind of
getting into what Canada looked like and
maybe still looks like uh my dad tells
the story I don't remember it as well
but he said he took me to the career
like not career that he took me to like
initiation at UBC like to check out the
campus and stuff and you know we're
driving my dad's 89 Camry and we pull
into the parking lot and Vancouver was
an interesting town in the early 2000s
because in 2000 uh Hong Kong seceded
from the British Empire and it went back
into Chinese Rule and so all the wealthy
people in Hong Kong it's one of the
wealthiest cities in the world they
moved their families to Vancouver
because there was more sort of certainty
in a democratic country so you know I'm
like a whitish looking guy obviously and
like at that time the university is
probably 90 Asian I mean that's just oh
that's just the demographic of Vancouver
like Vancouver is just that way I did
not know that yeah Vancouver is really
profound I don't know the total area but
I know that like at the University
there's many times on group projects
where like I have the best English and
I'm the one that wasn't born in the
country that's pretty normal in
Vancouver it's a normal Vancouver
experience I had no idea yes like I grew
up on like Chinese food I had a Chinese
girlfriend like that's just my friends
were Chinese it's just like that's fine
like that's just what it was okay but
there had so much money and so you know
you get into UBC and it's a very wealthy
School very wealthy area for you know
this demographic and the parking lot's
got like Lamborghini like straight up
Lamborghinis unlike Bentleys on it and
my dad uh tells me the story and I don't
remember it but he told me that he's
like when we went to the initiation day
when we're in the parking lot you my dad
said you looked at me and you said I'm
going to drive a car like that one day
but I'm gonna buy it for myself it won't
be you
wow because obviously the kids there
were getting the stuff and by the way
that's a very typical Vancouver
experience you'll see a lot of 19 20
year old kids driving Lambo so it's just
how it is
so um tell me you mentioned you had a
sales job yeah in in college yeah was
that your first job yeah I worked at a
gas station for three weeks and got
fired because I had all sorts of ideas I
think and whenever you're a creative
type of person I didn't know what that
meant it happened to me right sort of
they hated me in corporate because I was
always trying to put bring in like new
technology and stuff yeah that was me
yeah okay well I learned this later like
because people started referring to me
as being creative I didn't think I was
creative I didn't know what that meant
right
um
and so and so I got into the you know
the the whatever University and then I
was working a gas station for three
weeks I get fired because I just I'm
annoying my manager okay fine
um then I'm rollerblading to class
somebody approaches me he's like hey you
look like you're working you know your
your old brain to class you know you
really care about your Fitness and
motivation what I didn't say is like no
I can't afford the 75 cents a day
parking and I'm parking on the highway
taking a bus from because we had a free
bus pass and I lived about an hour and a
half from campus so I would drive uh to
like where I can park on the highway get
on the bus and then take the bus and
then get off the bus and rollerblade to
the campus Because the bus didn't go
like totally to campus um so it's like
that's why you're rollerbladed by the
highway oh yeah yeah but I'm like I'm
saving 75 cents I'm like I either look
more I don't know what I look like but I
was just poor I wasn't motivated I
rollerbladed in college too that's funny
not just for
yeah I was just you know with my bag and
like I just I needed to go to school and
you know I wasn't thinking about like
whatever I mean obviously I probably
look like a total loser because that's
what it was but somebody's like hey you
know I don't think you looked like a
loser no no no no no no no it's like
okay
there's something that people respect
about people that are just like crazy a
small percentage of people were
respected okay it's like when I um I was
telling the story yesterday on the show
how I was going door to door in
neighborhoods like asking for a job and
it was just more of a social experiment
but people respect it to be uh wealthy
people wealthy people yeah like people
that just don't care if they look stupid
they're trying to get it done listen I
buy from any salesperson that knocks on
my door and they're good oh but I don't
care what they're selling I'll buy it
because I respect the hustle and if they
look like they hate their job I won't
buy you know my family does that but
with kids lemonade stands I'll always
stop for a lemonade stand I'm like get
that money sure and I always pay like I
always give them like 20 bucks even
though it's 50 cents I had a funny story
on Sunday A door-to-door salesperson
came to our house in Estonia and my wife
bought whatever this person was selling
and then the person asked it's like can
you tell me about you know she's trying
to get like approach on other families
to like to like you know have a little
bit of a preparation before she knocks
on their door she's like and who lives
in this scene or that unit I'm always
like what do you mean she's like you
know this quartile this my wife's like
this is one house like the salesperson
thought that our house was a quad which
I'm like and I'm like baby we made it
you know that's that's like a really
nice
spaghetti it's one house this guy's been
to my house so
um
yeah so so somebody identified me as
being ambitious uh which okay I guess I
was more like just whatever but yeah I
got recruited to selling encyclopedias
door-to-door yeah and so yeah that was
crazy that was a tough sell that was it
was crazy and I remember
um you know knocking on doors that we
went to Ontario Ottawa and Toronto
because what happened was we relocated
for the entire summer like we literally
got in a caravan last day of finals and
we drove like 4 000 miles away from home
and we were just because that way we
can't quit it was like true Vega bond
from a van you know you live in a
basement with like six other dudes
you're working six days a week 14 15
hours a day just knocking on doors that
was the thing right and I'm like well I
got nothing better to go back to so why
not
um and you know it's like it's like
super hot I don't know about Fahrenheit
it's like 35 degrees Celsius 80 60
humidity you got nosebleeds just from
the humidity outside because they're
Smog and you're sometimes it rains and
you're knocking on doors like hi I want
to sell you some some encyclopedias
um but thankfully you know
um the lessons that that we gained from
that like perseverance positive
affirmation just making the best out of
a shitty situation and actually now that
I think back even just voluntarily
putting yourself through hardship
because that's a safe environment to
fail and it's not like a war that if you
fail you blow up it's like if you fail
you get rejected you might cry a little
bit but you're gonna have to pick
yourself back up and keep going and I
love that right especially for a man
again I can see to my own experience
like that right of passage experience
that and we don't have in North America
because there's no you know and there's
no
um there's no Army conscription you just
as a guy there's no rite of passage I
Believe In The Rite of Passage because I
went through that in that and thankfully
I discovered that um I'm okay at sales
and I have a certain passion for
influencing people
um and I like the thing that you know
that summer I came back I had eight
thousand dollar check it was not huge it
was eight thousand dollars but I was
able to pay off my tuition because it
was six thousand only tuition at the
time you know so kind of dating myself
here the next summer I went back I took
home a forty nine thousand dollar check
I saw an encyclopedias yeah so I bought
it so I bought my I was talking to the
encyclopedia Lopez go for it about 600
bucks wasn't that expensive but you just
you know you you learn yeah and then so
so like I was like
8K that was like 50 49 like 50 then like
50 then I jumped like 130k in one summer
geez so 23 this is how much my life
changed I was rollerblading to class at
20 at 23 I was 23 I was a full-time
University student I was paying my own
tuition tuition and I was a homeowner
wow so that was a really quick
turnaround right and so you went from
literally rollerblading to class yes
some guy I'm assuming he met it was a
lady
yeah the lady saw you um thought you
were ambitious yeah recruited you was it
her company no so it was it's a huge
company out of Nashville Tennessee and
they're like a big direct selling
company okay and so this company's been
around for like 160 170 years like
they've been around forever and he goes
look it was started by a pastor selling
Bible Store to Door like that was the
kind of origin story
um yeah and you know what's crazy is
obviously my friends all thought I was
signing up for like to be human
trafficked somewhere
right because they're like what and my
mom thought I was not she's like wait
you're gonna go four thousand miles away
from home and knock on door selling
books and and this is 2003 2004 my first
summer 2003 it's like we have Internet
and I'm like but Mom I think this will
be good for me you know I like I was
just feeling this drive after college no
this is in college this was the summer
this is the summer yeah all three so
every summer we would go for three
months and and you know sell and then of
course you know by my fourth I did five
years at University because of two
degrees by my fourth and fifth year I
would usually miss the first couple
weeks of school because I had sold so
much that I have to stay and like
deliver everything
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible